Nashville Tennessee and state capital of
the state of Tennessee and we continue
our special coverage on this Saturday
the radio television news Directors
Association meeting here for the last
four days we're waiting the arrival of
Frank mankiewicz from gray & Company who
you just saw on that panel and the
moderator ray depa for the last four
years have been news director
KETV Houma ha Nebraska and they're going
to join us right here in these two
chairs and we're going to take your
calls the numbers will be on your screen
two oh two six two eight two five two
five and two oh two seven eight three
two seven two seven mister mankiewicz
mr. Debra come on in we'll get you
seated and I was a little bit
complicated because we have our earplugs
in our telephone gear nice to see you
again
we'll get your hooked up to the mics
here in just a moment to get the mics on
the phone numbers on your screen you can
begin dialing now the subject for the
last hour and 15 minutes on the panel as
you well know was electronic news
releases and there was some disagreement
in the room we'll ask our two special
guests here in just a moment since we
get their microphones on to comment on
that later on today Jack Anderson the
syndicated columnist will speak to the
radio television news directors here in
Nashville at the Opryland Hotel and his
speech is scheduled to begin at 3
o'clock East Coast time 2 o'clock
Central Time following that at 4 o'clock
the radio television news directors have
a panel discussion on how to get your
story covered in Timbuktu or remain
within budget Tom Sanders vis News
Limited in New York an hour so and then
at 5:30
John Spain the president-elect of the
radio television news directors will be
here to take your calls believe we have
folks ready to go and want to get a
couple things that we heard during the
hour that might be worth explaining
I heard mr. mankiewicz talk about things
like supers and fonts and CG's and
voiceovers why don't we just for those
people who are watching this and the
audience explained with those simple
terms are so that they can have the same
information anyone else does here what's
a [ __ ]
well font is up is a word from print
journalism it's a it's a printing term
and it refers to the style of type what
it means is that when you see a little
line along the bottom of your television
screen that says Brian lamb c-span
that'll be in a certain kind of type
depending on the station each station
has its own distinctive style of type so
that if somebody were gonna send out a
piece of tape it would hope that that
station would use they wouldn't put your
name on the tape they would let the
station put your name on the tape
because it would want to do it in its
own style of type and that's a font the
type comes hey Deborah what's a super in
a CG well a super is Brian lamb the name
your name appears on the screen the
lower third of your screen so that the
viewers have a written identification of
you and that's what a super is CG a
character generator it's unlike that's
its electronically typed on the screen
and that's what that is those are our
technical issues and really are very
minor in terms of this discussion and
finally voiceover well voice over is
when you hear the voice and don't see
the picture of the person whose voice
you hear it's an off-screen voice how
much of grand companies business clients
today do you use this electronic news
release it's an increasing number I
don't have a figure in my head but I
would say probably a third to a half of
our clients make use from time to time
of the service earlier before this panel
patent a love television digest was here
in which he said he couldn't believe
that anyone had ever used one of these
electronic news releases but I want to
make sure we we did not have the right
information on the Morocco story would
you explain to us what that controversy
was over the Morocco story gonna get
enough because we were saying it was
Jordan and that was my fault but I want
to make sure that we have just enough
information to clear it out that was a
release that we were going to do from
Morocco we had a crew over there to do
an interview with with the king the
government of Morocco is a client of
grain companies we did a piece the
person we had over there the grain
company person there and knew somebody
from CNN the people from CNN saw her
doing the piece said we might like that
let us take a look at it would Jen maybe
we'll use it so she let him look at it
they took it to London liked it and fed
it before we had had a chance to do
anything with it and it was picked up by
a station in the States but as it turned
out there wasn't any damage because the
station in the states had picked it up
knew the source although in fact on the
tape it did not have the legend where it
came from it would have if we had fed it
but the damage was minimal because
nobody used the tape who didn't know the
source right at your station in Omaha
k-e-t-v have you ever used one of these
electronic news releases not in whole
but we have used parts of releases when
we develop stories locally and whenever
a part of an electronic news release is
used it's clearly identified as to where
that was received my guests right is
there isn't a television station in the
country that hasn't used an electronic
those release one time or another any
other they all use them whether they
come from NASA whether they come from
the White House or from 20th Century Fox
or the National Football League if you
see sports highlights on a news program
in the evening that's an electronic news
release it came from the International
Football League how many have a major
league baseball how many of the ones
that you produce end up getting used
well they all get used some by a lot of
stations some by a few station but we
target usually we we rarely put on an
electronic news release that is intended
for every station in the country it
might be intended for stations in
Northern California or for stations in
the southwest or for stations with an
Indian tribe within their viewing
audience if that's the the client and
and so when we when it's announced that
the thing is coming then we make phone
calls to 10 15 50 stations that we hope
will use it and talk to them about it
and we get a pretty good response rate
depo what was your reaction to the panel
discussion today what do you think you
learned
well I think we learned that we use them
even some news directors who say they
don't use them use them I think that a
number of very good points and issues
were discussed openly there are some
that are extremely blatant and in most
instances those are not used they're
thrown away or they're sent back but
there are instances when the use of a
part of an electronic news release might
be appropriate I thought the example
that was used by George Glaser in the
Gatorade situation was a responsible use
of an of an electronic and news release
the station simply doesn't have or could
take the time to do that kind of a thing
and you were talking then about how to
have a health situation but then there
are those examples on the extreme where
you've got 60 seconds out of a minute
and a half of a maestro brow plastered
all over a release where it's a purely
commercial yeah no nothing was resolved
and I and I think just as in any news
story there are a different set of
circumstances and all of the
circumstances need to be weighed based
on how important that information is for
your viewer make sure Frank if you've
got your ear plug plugged into that
little box on the side over there can
you see if you do I want to if you're
not you won't be able to hear the calls
yeah I'm not sure that's the right yeah
I'll get right in there we want to make
sure that you can hear what the years
have to say and what they're asking the
numbers are on the screen to go to six
to eight to five two five and two to
seven eight three to seven two seven
begin dialing now if you have a question
or a comment about the idea of
electronic news releases for our two
guests here from Washington DC we have
Frank mankiewicz executive vice
president grain company that's a tight
butt and Wright depo who is the news
director of KETV TV in Omaha Nebraska
did you hear anything in the panel
discussion from the members of that
surprised you the impression I got that
surprised me a little bit was at the
consent and it pleased me was that the
concern is mostly over rather blatantly
commercial electronic news releases that
is things that plug a product we're
really not
that business we're talking about points
of view of public issues and I didn't
hear very much objection to that and I
think as I said I think I think
everybody uses them in one form or
another go to the phones we have a cost
anybody from Odessa Texas go ahead
please I would like to know why you
people haven't got the guts when you get
on a big news story to tell the truth
instead of telling what you think people
want to hear I'm going back to the
situation in Beirut when our president
sent Marines to their death what's one
of you have got the guts to stand up and
tell it thank you it's a little bit off
217 I might ask our viewers there if you
can phrase your questions relevant to
what the discussion was here if Ray Depa
wants to respond you're certainly
welcome to what is the truth I I guess a
part of our job is to find it and and in
most instances it just isn't right there
to be found that the the truth is
usually someplace in between somewhere
and do you go out and you you and
explore the the different issues and
involved here and it just isn't right
there in the middle of the table and not
that the media ever holds anything back
and I think the caller there was asking
for the media to take a definite
position on something and that's simply
not our role right well I think that
gentleman from from Edessa
had obviously a real emotional
connection with that issue and I think
he's on to something I think the media
are much too deferential to people in
authority particularly President the
United States not just this one but all
presidents and are very reluctant to say
often what seems quite evident
because it seems controversial and seems
to be taking sides I I think the news
for that reason seems to get more and
more bland with each passing controversy
Las Vegas Nevada go ahead please
right I have a as two specific questions
one is on education and one is on the
technology if I could ask Frank
mankiewicz the question on education I'm
graduating UNLV Universal Nevada Las
Vegas in social sciences and they I've
been taking for the past year so some
communication courses I want to know
educationally what one could expect to
break in entry level in the news
department what might be the
availability of referral across
countries and technically what I'd like
to know is where did the transmission
emanate from is there one is there one
satellite to choose and and how much is
an uplink excuse me how much is enough
link okay thank you
Las Vegas first thing both of you can
get on that education question he wants
to find a job doesn't they well that's
understandable
I think I don't know I'll tell you that
where I work the people I hire generally
do not have degrees in communications
and in public relations in fact I I look
pretty hard at that I hope people would
have degrees in history economics
English literature science and to
indicate that they've spent their time
at a college or university learning
something beside the techniques of
public relations which are things you
can learn over the years much more
easily and better than you can in a in a
classroom life I tend to downgrade
people with degrees in journalism and in
communications but there certainly is
there plenty of openings a lot of
entry-level jobs in public relations and
then public communications as I assume
there are in those how do you hire right
well we hire people with a track record
with experience Omaha is the 69th
largest television market in the country
we do not hire beginners as
College we look for people who have a
couple of years experience in smaller
situations or who perhaps the work in
larger cities and who are tired of the
rat race and are willing to settle down
and work in a pretty good news market in
an operation that in a city that has
three very competitive news stations and
spend some money and make a decent wage
so I would if the caller is a broadcast
journalism student I would recommend
that he look in smaller cities and spend
a year or two developing his
communication skills quick answer to the
uplink electronic news releases well the
the answer the first question is there's
there's competition among satellite
owners different satellites reach
different stations and different
patterns and sometimes stations have to
switch off to get one rather than
another so it's a question to which one
serves your needs best the uplink cost
is a few hundred dollars depending on
when and how and where Mobile Alabama go
ahead please your next caller Brian
first of all I'm a news director at a
radio station in Mobile and I want to
thank you for putting this program on
because I can't be in Nashville but it's
very nice to be able to check out what's
happening up there as far as the
electronic news releases are concerned I
receive these all the time in mobile
especially from the chemical
Manufacturers Association there are
times when I have checked those out but
I'll have to say like we said earlier I
do not use those mostly because I feel
like they are somewhat biased and I
don't want to give the point of view of
being biased
on my news broadcast as you know we have
one the largest chemical landfills in
the entire United States and West
Alabama and so the they are trying to
lobby I think a lot of folks in the
Mobile and surrounding areas to try to
put pressure on the Congress and so
forth to provide that extra money for
super funds and so forth
and mobile let me ask you if you get any
value at all maybe you don't use them on
the air but do you listen to them and
does that help your news
yes Brian I do I listen to them mostly
from my own background information so
when I do come up with some information
that I need to put on the air then I'm
trying to get as complete of you as
possible and I feel like that is I hope
to me personally so that I don't have a
bias if you see what I mean Frank
mankiewicz and that's how we've been
using written as releases for years not
all of them are thrown away there
they're placed in a file where you can
background yourself we don't put
everything on the air that we receive in
written form either and I don't I I see
I don't see a distinction in their use
between printed audio or video releases
in that regard do you have some of the
same velocity when you send them out
that part of this is just for
information well I think we hope that
somebody's looking at it sure that's a
white well not necessarily not
necessarily uh it's a little bit like
protesting a decision at second base the
umpires not going to change his mind but
maybe you'll think about it the next
time you come roaring in San Francisco
our next car go ahead please only
printing what they want the free print
and they only print have routes well it
happens to be happening fast now with
the electronic media I was read an
article a couple weeks ago in the New
York Times which was talking about how
the blacks in South Africa had to be
educated and referred to the education
riot of 1976 they didn't tell you what
the what the riot was actually about
where the blacks didn't want to learn
their courses bilingually and they only
wanted to learn in English because it
was an international language so they
took all their Afrikaans books and
started burning them which are shows you
that they don't want to learn but the
newspapers only talk about the white
racist regime they don't talk about how
many black tribes are actually are and
how many tribals the tribal differences
are actually causing the killings down
with people from different clubs
actually killing each other ok San
Francisco thanks for the call truth
again white tribes have been known to
kill each other from time to time the
great massacres in history have been
done by whites which is no reason to
feel that whites are inferior to require
blacks in an in an english-speaking
country to study in their own
language which the whites decide is
their own language is a racist act I
think that was quite properly described
on truth ray how often do you have a
problem that when you wish you'd done
something well certainly we you know you
you a number of instances you can always
go back and say I could have done a
better job here but a lot of it too
depends on the point of view of the
person who is receiving the message I've
had people call our newsroom and
complain because we had both sides they
already have a definite idea of what's
going on and how dare you put something
contrary to what I feel on the air so
you know a lot depends on how that
message is received and the perceptions
of the individuals I think most of the
claims of bias by the news media come
from people who are hearing for the
first time a point of view opposed to
the one they have always accepted as the
received truth water rapids George our
next caller go ahead please yes I like
that Bertie got over with the new
coca-cola oh okay thank you did you
write is Coco Lee one of your clients no
nope
any of you know one of you have a
feeling about the whole coca-cola I
don't understand how anybody could have
thought people would prefer the new to
the old but that's a personal judgement
I have any was perhaps the best
conceived public relations gimmick ever
oh I don't know I came out of it looking
fairly well I they came out smelling
what you did let's talk just for a
moment take our next call about your two
organizations Frank mankiewicz how long
have you been at grain company a little
over two years but prior to that you
were a National Public Radio that's
right now years ago press secretary
former song arrived and along the way a
journalist a journalist so you've been
on both sides of this issue grain
company how big is it how many people
work there what did it do for those
who've never never we have about a
hundred one hundred ten hundred fifteen
employees
then we have a subsidiary great straight
and international mostly in the
high-tech area which has another 50 or
60 in three or four locations around the
country based on all of our branch
offices and Washington total probably
about 175 and your primary job is to do
what Frank well we have two primary jobs
lobbying and public relations in behalf
of clients ray depa you're stationed in
Omaha how big is that who you affiliated
with how BIG's your newsroom we're an
ABC affiliate I have 35 full-time
employees our station is owned by the
Pulitzer Company which is headquartered
in st. Louis publishes the Post Dispatch
founded by Joseph Pulitzer our company
owns seven television stations around
the country two radio stations and
another newspaper in Tucson Arizona
what do you both think of what's going
on with satellites and the electronic
information is there too much
information available to the public now
I don't think there's ever too much
information available I think the
problem in a lot of television news
departments right now is that we tend to
let the technology dictate some of the
actions that we take and there's there's
too much of a tendency to be awed by the
capabilities and certainly those are
excellent tools but it scares you you
know you when you can go to an event
anywhere in the world now and get a live
picture back what are you showing people
right I'll never forget the pictures of
the live pictures of the aftermath of
the plane crash in Washington DC where
cameras very graphically and vividly
through the networks and all over the
country showed people the carnage that
occurred there that bothered me you have
no control over those kinds of
situations you know there are there have
been instances where people
organizations and groups will attempt to
take advantage of that technology
how many anti-abortion demonstrations
occur now during early news broadcasts
so you know though there are the tech
technology is great but it also creates
a number of problems mr. mankiewicz bun
there's a great story about the role and
Emerson as there is about almost any
issue but this is a particularly good
one in which it is said that that
Emerson said to Thoreau Henry said this
there's wonderful news
the cable has been put in place and main
may now speak to Texas and throw thought
for a while and then he said well he
said what if Maine has nothing to say
the Texas the and that's the point
really that ray is trying to make we
have these wonderful ways to communicate
but there's still a limited number of
things that we want to communicate and
there's still the limited intelligence
of us communicators and as long as
that's the situation the technology is
probably going to outstrip us a little
bit I mean there are wonderful ways now
with satellites and and vivid new ways
to to feed the information so that it's
very says anything on earth can be seen
by everybody else at the moment that it
occurs but what if it's not worth seeing
that's the question that the news
directors still have to decide and
they're the same people they were when
you couldn't do that Terre Haute Indiana
go ahead please you're on the air hi
Bryan I'd like to really not really ask
a question I just like to make some
comments it's okay I went into media in
1962 and worked in local TV stations as
an art director for four years and it's
amazing how things have changed in terms
of the way the media addresses the
public and the way the public listens to
the media a lot of Education has taken
place during this time in terms of
people watching TV and the scholastic
level for a long time media was very
resistant to addressing anything above
an eighth grade level I know locally
this was true also media was pretty well
treated as a public relations outlet
they really didn't want to get into the
details it was something they just
didn't do and that's changed a lot it's
changed fantastically because television
as the gentleman was saying about the
carnage and whatnot
it does take us there and there's a
great culture shock here and a lot of
people just can't take it but I think
media is doing a fantastic job
well of educating us because this is the
electronic village Marshall McLuhan was
right on it it's future shock and we're
right in it and the media is doing a
great job I don't think they have to
apologize to anybody as long as they do
in like the your your network is amazing
crossfire is great here you get the sim
live warts and all
and it's the thing I would like to see
media do all media if they would would
be to give us all a course in what is
the conservative and what is a liberal
now this is something that we all
individually have our ideas about and
you talk to a conservative but he'll
tell you what his conservative group
thinks they are you talk to a liberal or
he'll tell you what he thinks his group
is but the question is what are they all
right thanks for the call ray do you
want to start with his coming about to
me he says the media is doing a great
job you think thank you and I well I I
do I do believe we're doing we can do a
better job are you listening to the
public well no we're not and that's been
that's been one of the the real problems
I think this studies have shown that
many people believe us to be arrogant
that we refuse to admit when we've made
mistakes that when we do we hide them
someplace in our broadcasts or we
publish them back on page 30 yeah we we
don't do a good enough job responding to
inquiries to letters we get very
defensive and we need to take a very
good look at that but I in terms of
covering the news we certainly would
want to do better but I but I thought I
believe that we're making very good use
of the resources were given to work with
us to mankiewicz did you write a book
about primetime television I did indeed
it was called remote control what year
we might as well sell a book here we go
1977 okay out of print I assume not
quite not quite I don't know of anybody
competent to teach that course that
gentlemen Terre Haute suggested will as
a conservative what is a liberal if
anybody were competent they probably
wouldn't that is to say if they were
neutral enough they probably wouldn't
know enough about the subject if they
knew enough about the subject to be
disqualified from teaching by reason of
bias
I think everybody's got a reach his or
her own decision on that go back to Las
Vegas but if they got problems what do
you think the poor consuming public out
here there were in the midst of the
telecommunications expose explosion I
was particularly interested in the Texas
news network story at the Florida news
network story I think it was put
interestingly enough we get news from
Bhopal India pastors we get it from a
town 200 miles away and I'm very
interested in exploiting that sort of
thing because here in Nevada we've got a
big state and a lot of new stories it's
break all around if we don't get it
and if I don't get it on the air during
this program I'll call your station
later c-span later and see if there's
some sort of organization which will
help us promote it in the thing okay
thank you Las Vegas it brings up a lot
of interesting things to talk about
satellite news gathering seems to be one
of the top things that came out of this
meeting back behind here are 11 12 up
links on little trucks that run around
they can literally drive out to a site
and be on the satellite in 30 minutes do
you think that's going to change your
life ray oh you bet and because the
another station in my market just bought
one of those trucks that's gonna change
my life immensely trucks costing come
hundred thousand well if you can find
one for a couple hundred let me know
where you get it there are four hundred
thousand dollars just for the hardware
and
get how you get the picture up you've
got to buy satellite time and all those
kinds of things but but you know again I
think satellite news gathering I've told
this to my boss in corporate offices
since the development of electronic
newsgathering the ability to put
something on the air live by microwave
this is the biggest technological
advance in our in our industry at a
station in Las Vegas Nevada can buy one
of these trucks and drive it to
Winnemucca and get a feedback as quickly
as they get something back from Bhopal
India heretofore we've been limited to
where we can find up links good or bad
for us mister mankiewicz oh I think it's
good I think anything that makes more
information available is good but there
again the question is who's going to
make the judgments about which
information to descend on which to
receive and having received at all what
do you put on the air and when you moved
beyond the uplink technology that we now
have to digital technology so that in
effect a picture is going to be
available at the end of a telephone line
then you've tripled the the availability
of I hesitate to use the word news but
of information which may or may not be
news no it's going to change everybody's
life dramatically it's one of the few
areas in which the future is really here
the rest of it is still a lot of pie in
the sky I think but but in terms of
communication in terms of the
transmission of of information the
future is really here and the bursting
on us and it's going to change our lives
in a lot of ways if that Las Vegas
station drives to Winnemucca to cover a
ribbon-cutting live they've not used
that equipment properly they've not
served a purpose but if they take that
truck to Carson City and do thoughtful
interviews with state government
officials to beam them back to Las Vegas
to increase the understanding of those
issues and they performed a service and
that's the key not what we use but how
we use it
Morton Pennsylvania go ahead please okay
Brian I just want to congratulate you
and your staff for having one of the
most valuable cable networks and my
question is towards Ray I live in in the
outskirts of Philadelphia which is the
fourth largest market
and what I find is that the local
affiliates in this area produce as much
as three hours of local news every day
but they seem to when they come on at
5:00 and run until 6:30 but they use a
lot of network packages and so forth
rather than concentrating on the local
aspect the news or some of these other
organizations such as newsfeed which
have these human interest stories can
you comment on that
let me ask Eric : are you in this
business yeah I'm in the cable
television business cable television
business okay
right oh I've never worked in a large
market but I have visited large market
stations and I wonder how they ever get
on the air with material bigger and more
isn't always better and it bothers me
too to see large market stations
devoting a lot of their time to network
packages they've got staffs of over a
hundred people we devote very little of
our time to net we do we never run a
network package unless it's something
that's so complicated it's difficult to
rewrite and recut the preponderance of
news on our station or Omaha is local
news obviously at ten o'clock we attempt
to provide a wrap-up of world events but
most of the stuff we put on the air that
is local news let me ask Frank
mankiewicz in andrade depe about this
new thing that Stan Hubbard out of
Minnesota is doing called CONUS and
there are other people in the same
business where they will Park that
satellite truck across the street from
the White House feed out live any
announcement coming out of the White
House or presidential speech directly to
your station if you want to subscribe to
this system therefore bypassing the
three commercial networks is that going
to give the network's a lot of trouble
in the future I think it will it's it's
a form of direct form of DBS isn't it of
Direct broadcast satellite in which you
bypass not only the which you bypass to
the network the next step will be to
bypass the local station in which you'll
be able to transmit directly to the home
then you'll hear a lot of complaints at
the moment it's only the network's
complaining the local affiliates are in
the driver's seat when they are bypassed
you'll see a unity in the TV industry
that may postpone that technological
development for some time sure it's
going to change and for the time being
what it does is give an enormous
advantage to people with the financial
capability to do that kind of thing to
the White House for example the Pentagon
major companies major institutions they
will have the edge for quite a while
because they have the they have the four
hundred thousand dollars to buy that
truck I think network in our area for
instance networks do a horrible job
covering agriculture it gets very little
coverage the only time they come out is
when a right-wing survivalist group is
discovered and they unearth bodies on
farms but a pretty good story it is a
dog gun doggone good story and I'd go
out too but I see some advantages there
where where there are agricultural kinds
of issues that are explored that the
network's don't cover that we have the
capability than of picking off yeah
ourself yeah I call the other day we do
the same kind of thing a grand company
we try to cover I mean our clients want
to cover a story want a story covered
obviously because they're involved
they're on one side or the other of the
issue whether it's agriculture or or
whatever it might be and so we're able
through the electronic news release to
do that in the same way that raised
station is able but it's the same thing
it's it's presenting to the viewer
material that is not made available by
the networks that makes sense
Los Angeles your next go ahead please
yes I worked in radio news and some
television news for a dozen years and
when I as an editor and when I finally
left the general manager of the station
asked me why I was leaving and I said
I'm tired of being a PR man for the SWAT
team and it seems like all the local
television stations and radio stations
have this preoccupation with brush fires
and light plane crashes are all news
stations in Los Angeles give traffic
reports every 10 minutes instead of
having using those resources and
personnel to cover things that are
really important local city state
governments federal governments and
really explaining issues to the people
there seems to be this preoccupation
with things that are easy to cover and
it leads me to the question do you think
that the people who are going into the
news business are not capable of doing
anything but brush brush fires and light
plane crashes and police and fire stuff
and barricades
and also radio and television stations
don't want to rock the boat
any time somebody complains they've got
to answer it and so they discover what's
there what's easy and what they're
people who are uneducated basically in
terms of politics government economics
history geography are capable of
covering they they just opt for that
because it's easy it looks good it
sounds good and it doesn't require very
much brains or research you know how can
the media fulfill their obligation to
inform the public when they've got they
don't have the people or the desire to
really get into issues Thank You Los
Angeles mr. Mack well I think you've
touched on a very important question
it's not just that it's easy but it's
also profitable we lose sight when we
talk about news of the fact that we're
not engaged in some great exciting
public enterprise here we're in commerce
the purpose of television has never been
to inform or to educate or to instruct
or even to titillate the purpose of
television at any given moment it's to
deliver the largest possible audience to
the advertiser and news people have
discovered too many of them that that
can be done with a fire or a plane crash
or traffic because in Los Angeles
particularly what are people doing the
driving around their cars and they're
listening to the radio and it's easy not
only easy to do but people will stay on
whereas if you if you tune in your radio
and you're stuck on the Santa Monica
freeway westbound and what are you
hearing a discussion of interest rates
or Special Drawing rights through the
International Monetary Fund and you want
to know if the La Cienega off-ramp is
jammed you're going to go to another
station so that feeds on itself but
that's a major failing in in electronic
news is that the trivial will always
drive out the serious and if there's
tape of a nighttime fire it'll be used
right now from the Washington
translation of that is if somebody
testifies in a ski mask they'll get on
the air not all of that information is
unimportant no that's true that's true
and I do agree with a caller and I think
the word
see is a good one it's been too easy to
cover these kinds of things you can pull
up behind an ambulance and follow it to
the scene and you always get quote good
pictures unquote and and another point
that no but I think that's changing and
again I've never worked in a major
market what I see on in a top 10 markets
is is I don't like that's why I prefer
to work in Omaha Nebraska because we can
get into these kinds of things not that
we don't cover accidents or fires we do
and I think we should but you don't see
us as ambulance chasers well we do
attempt to go out and do those stories a
real challenge is to make those
seemingly boring stories interesting how
does that 5 to 2 vote at the City
Council impact on you the viewer of the
consumer the those kinds of things and
those are the kinds of things that we
try to explore a lot of television
stations years ago abdicated their
responsibility to consultants another
thing that obsessed me there are people
getting into this business for the wrong
reasons they want to be on television
they're starstruck and it's upsetting
great deaf have spent time served time
in Wichita Kansas has a wall headed guys
they served with as it kgu n kg you
wanna Tucson Tucson also at wo WT
television in Omaha number of years ago
New York City go ahead please most
people be pretty obscure thing your
selection is a bona fide news story and
to give it such extensive coverage I
think is very commendable before I get
to my question
listen to the last question while I was
waiting on hold and hearing Frank
mankiewicz his answer that that the
commercial dynamic is what's gonna
always dictate you know all the car
crashes and the fires and everything I'm
amazed that that in responding to that
question you say something about the
role of the non-commercial media like
c-span for example or you know more to
the point National Public Radio or PBS
because you know these are the outlets
that we have available now to kind of go
against that
that's the comments on my main question
which I wanted to ask you about which is
sort of a similar game to Frank
mankiewicz is regarding these visual
news releases doesn't the acceptance by
all the TV and radio station or the TV
stations and the equivalent with the
sound bytes for radio doesn't that kind
of change the terms of the date and the
news between the the Public Interest
sector in the corporate sector what I'm
saying is that the is the Public
Interest sector like the Public Interest
Research Group the curves the Ralph
Nader organizations the ACLU these
groups aren't in a position to put out
these kinds of digital news releases
their lack of financial resources give
them a less competitive edge in the
attention of the news directors and
there's another news gathering process
and I think this is you know to me the
most dangerous and insidious aspect of
being being tired today and I didn't
even see that issue addressed during the
conference and I thought mr. Manku it's
because you know if you're a particular
sensibility both you know from your
political background and running NPR you
know particularly the Jewish McGovern
campaign I would think that uh you know
you'd be a little bit more sensitive to
that issue and and we're once the
estate's become look 10 15 20 years down
the road once it becomes like really
really acceptable to just left and right
the easy these corporate traditional
news releases what is that going to say
about the public interest segments are
they are they going to have a harder
time getting to the attention of news
directors and also even even when they
get the attention of the news directors
isn't it always going to be the case
that that a newscaster anchormen reading
a script is never going to make as
powerful a statement in the presentation
of the public interest organizations
news as when they're able to run a video
clip coming from the corporate side
aren't they always going to be in a
weaker position as a result Thank You
New York City you want to start on that
one here yeah and I think it's a very
important question and and I think we're
we are sensitive to it and I know I've
thought a lot about that the fact is of
course that the public interest groups
have greater access
initially the
the individual corporate responses that
we were talking about this morning Ralph
Nader ACLU Mauro majority on all sides
whoever these people are particularly
government have enormous access that's
where news directors go first they have
an enormous public relations operation
as well they should and I contribute to
a fair share of them so that it really
isn't a question of no balance the
corporate access to news directors is
very slim and I might also point out
that a grand company and I assume at
some of the other public relations
agencies as well our clients in terms of
electronic news releases are as likely
to be organizations as they are to be
corporations so this isn't entirely
one-sided there's plenty of electronic
news releases coming from what your
caller would refer to as the Public
Interest organizations they have
substantial clout now and I don't think
the growth of electronic news releases
has done more than then create a balance
in which some of these issues can be
more more effectively illuminated right
now well you know your a statement that
corporate access to news directors has
been slim as is telling it not by our
choice but by the corporation well in
part sure you know high no news is good
news that's the phrase that many of the
corporations in there they're very
hesitant to talk to you they won't
return your phone calls they're they're
afraid of the media to do something to
it to it to some extent it sometimes
with good cause good cars yes and and
here's our effort to get their side of
the story and they've not been willing
to tell that side now they're telling
that side on the thing that bothers me
on their terms in their turf through
their cameras through being coached on
how to deal with the media yeah if the
day ever comes that we that you'll see
wall-to-wall news releases from any
organization where it be the the the
public interest groups and the
corporation's my gosh what have we done
oh I think of what you've done is to
a modern newscast I would guess that
there are a number of newscast today
that our wall-to-wall press releases
that is to say the information in each
case came to the attention of the
organization through a press release of
some kind and when you're talking about
coaching you have no problem with
putting on the President of the United
States or a united states senator or a
governor who's spending an enormous
amount of public funds your tax money in
mind to be coached on how to reach the
media surely a corporate executive is
entitled to try to try to match that
it's simply a question of access and
mostly of your judgment that's really
the that's really the question I mean
you you must look at a hundred print
press releases a day if you don't the
the people in your market are not
serving themselves well because they
ought to be putting those in your hands
and you look at you say well here's the
story
and you take a reporter and you say go
look at this story now that story came
to you because somebody sent your press
release but when it comes out on the air
it's your story and not that of the
organization reported and that's the way
it should but the reporter has
embellished on that and it's developed
absolutely when you're handed a minute
and a half final segment ah from a from
a from a corporation or from like my
advice to you is do not use when we
don't and I think use and I think that's
what you heard of that the seminar
before is we don't we don't send them
out I think more more and more public
relations agencies will be doing what we
do which is to send you in effect the
press release that is cuz they send you
some sound bites send you some b-roll
you can use this background for your own
voiceover and then you get a reporter on
it and develop that story that's you
said b-roll for the audience and that's
alright you mean well that's shots of
the activity going on in a neutral way
that is to say if it's a sports story
b-roll would be a crowd coming to its
feet and cheering or or people walking
along a street if it's a story about
about whether it might be people taking
off their coats and perspiring just
something to illuminate the the matter
that you can put on the screen while the
reporter is setting the scene
the story special gas rate depo is a
news director of KETV in Omaha Nebraska
and the executive vice president of
grain company Frank mankiewicz we have a
lot coming up for you from Nashville
here at the Opryland hotels the rest of
the day brings you the RT NDA conference
there's still more callin programs and
interviews and also Jack Anderson will
address this convention at 3 o'clock
East Coast time this afternoon former
Governor of Tennessee Winfield Dunn who
is expected to be a candidate once again
in 1986 for governor will be interviewed
in the next half hour here next week
Senate television is once again under
discussion Senate Rules Committee 9:30
on Tuesday live hearings on whether or
not this televised the Senate we go now
to our next call California I cannot
pronounce your town what is it up one
okay thank you very much go ahead please
near Ontario I really don't have a
question it's a comment for mister depe
I used to live in Omaha Richard depa and
I used to watch here news casts and I
think you guys are doing one heck of a
job out there
I mean I've noticed a lot of the news
story for a rain Li human-interest and
you guys did a heck of a job out but I
just want to say keep up the good work
thank you thanks a lot upland okay when
tack nail was on here earlier from
television digest he said the only
reason you have these RTM day
conferences so you can all come down and
look for other jobs and get together
with your buddies and a few other things
you want to defend that right there but
why do you come to these conventions I'm
not here looking for a job other people
are looking for it become one of the
biggest employment centers in the
the year well you come down here for
discussions that we've had issues of
news content the technological kinds of
things you come to one place and look at
all of the bells and whistles that are
available you hope that your general
manager brings along the checkbook you
also circulate and talk to people from
different parts of the country getting
ideas from them on the TV Thank You
Harrison broad question what what about
that you wanna start ray well I can't
use something from the hospital well you
can but you want to identify it
I've yet to get any tape from a hospital
whose botched and operate well that's
right there but there are practical
considerations would you want to be on
the operating table and have and have
six camera crews in that operating room
well I assume you that'll give the I
assume you'd have to give permission I
think an answer to the caller the reason
is that the hospital is using that tape
to sell the hospital they're not going
to put anything on the air they're not
going to send you a tape as ray says of
a botched operation of a delayed
operation if a doctor in the middle of
the operation says to the nurse where
the hell is that
damnit I asked you for it five minutes
ago that's going to be cut out of the
tape whereas if the station is doing its
own its own taper but they're gonna take
all of it it's simply a question of
realism it's simply a question of
knowing that what you've got is the
operation as it happened rather than the
operation as the hospital wants you to
think it happens so I might have wanted
you to think it happened excuse me
Salinas California next go ahead please
yes I have a comment for the gentleman
from Omaha I'm from the flat my country
back there to the low place called
Holdridge and the thing about news I was
interested in listeners your comments
about major markets and small markets I
would think that the small markets are
more interest in the local things like
even the police blotter as you will
we're out here they don't even fit and
another question I would like to ask is
something you've been of interest to me
recently Cable News Network and ESPN is
going to scramble their single signal in
regards to people with dishes my
question to essentially do a heavy
amount of advertising such as your
networks do why are they so concerned
about having a fee paid right now to be
able to pick up their signals by the
dish and I will go off the air and pick
you up on the TV can I can hear you too
good okay okay Salinas thank you that is
a question we talked about for about six
hours the scrambling of signals you
don't if you have an opinion on that
well I'm a newsman but I would think
that if I could get cable television
without paying for it then the cable
operators are gonna be very happy about
that I guess it speaks to their revenue
potential well I think it's an
indication by the network's the cable
networks that are doing it that at the
moment they're getting more revenue from
viewers than they are from advertisers
if the if the dish phenomenon becomes
widespread enough so that they can then
get additional advertising revenues
because hundreds of thousands millions
of people are now watching the program
who weren't watching it before then I
would assume they'll withdraw their
objections but at the moment they're
right
they're putting out something for money
and people have figured out a way to get
it for free so now they're taking the
step to see that that can't happen but
if that's a battle that's gonna go on
for some time I find a little bit of
irony here because when cable first came
on the scene commercial broadcasters
were screaming that jeez these pirates
they're taking my signal and and not
paying me anything for it and now cable
companies don't have to carry my signal
up with a must carry rule I mean the
more it changes the more it remains the
same where the cycle keeps coming around
by the way we'll be in Indianapolis
Indiana
week after next on the 25th 26th 27th
for the Great Lakes cable television
exposition and also visiting on another
state capital Indianapolis we'll be
talking with the governor and the mayor
of that city the governor of the state
and a lot of other legislators meet gene
Pulliam the publisher of Indianapolis
Star and visit with some folks from
Indianapolis news we just have a couple
of minutes left and when I ask our
special guest to Frank mankiewicz
whether your electronic news release
business for your clients is steadily
growing yes yes I would think that's
probably true of everyone in the
business but certainly a grand company
that business is increasing almost
incrementally because the technology has
made it quite reasonable for clients to
furnish stations like raise with pieces
of information which if it's done well
and done of high quality and done with
integrity they can put into their news
program are you doing it more and more
we're getting are you doing it because
that you think it's a good thing for the
clients or the clients want you to do it
well it's both and we frequently have to
resist it a client will come and say
here we think we want to go on the air
with this we want to have a news story
on it and we will say quite frankly mr.
client we don't think very many news
directors maybe none will want that
story and while we'd like to have the
fee for it you'll be dissatisfied
because it isn't going to get on the air
so that discussion takes place and now
the more sophisticated ones are saying
well do you think this or do you think
that and we're able to advise them in
counseling but the business is on the
increase there's no question of it from
your angle right definitely are you
seeing more and more come through the
door what do you do with all those
Swain's a week are you gonna handle it
in the future you get those things a
week how many did you get a year ago
half a dozen yeah three or four a week I
send most of them back if there is a
medical thing I might give it to our
medical reporter and have that person
look at it possibly generate an idea as
you would often release but the thing I
guess but I wanted to stress here as we
as we close is that we have to be good
reporters in this business but our edit
responsibilities are equally or is more
important than that and just because we
receive them doesn't mean we have to use
them and and that those are the kinds of
things we ought to keep in mind if we
only had another hour we could talk
about the impact of all of us on
politics and unfortunately we are out of
time I'd love to hear with you that's ok
great Frank mankiewicz executive vice
president of grading company or a depe
who is the news director of KETV Oh
Mahalo Braska our special guest during
the last hours we talked about
electronic news releases and that's it
for this hour thank you for being with
us and thanks to the Opryland Hotel bud
Wendell who runs the entire Opryland
organization and also the folks here at
the Opryland Hotel have been so doggone
nice to us over the last four days we
really appreciate it and hope to come
back here soon we have a lot more
programming for the rest of the
afternoon for those of you who are
leaving us this